(Sad music playing)
Why?
I'm so irresponsible and before you guys
criticize me, I'm going to say all the terrible things
About myself, I'm an idiot, I'm careless, I'm reckless
Accidents happens.
Oh my god!
The same exact thing that
happened the last time I shattered my phone
happened again.
I'm holding my dog,
in this hand,
And the phone, also in this hand,
He pulls, and the phone just drops.
Oh.
I just... Mattie why?
Why did you break mama's phone?
I can't blame the dog, he doesn't know any better.
He just want to go for a walk.
Thankfully I have a Genius Bar appointment
In an hour.
As soon as I picked my phone up, I was like,
Oh god. Again.
And I was able to schedule it as quickly as possible.
So what I have to do now,
Because the last time, that I made this mistake,
I backed up everything to iCloud.
And it took almost 3 weeks to backup
All my photos and everything.
So I deleted the backup from iCloud,
I'm now gonna backup onto my computer.
I need a USB-C!
Lightning to USB-C,
How do I back this up...
My appointment is at 2 o'clock,
So that means, hopefully
This will backup within 45 minutes.
I have no idea how long this is gonna take,
But I hope it goes quick.
And why didn't put this on my screen,
sooner, and you probably also wonder,
Justine, why did you remove
The glass protection that you just told us,
That you put on your phone,
So I removed the glass screen,
Because I was going to reapply it
Cause there is a big bubble,
and I did a terrible job putting it on
And guess what I never did? I never put it back on.
So, Justine, you're an idiot, it's your fault.
You're so stupid.
But I brought this the other day,
And I never even put it on my phone
Cause I was like, I would like to try the other one first.
Because the other screen that I had,
Had a little black edge along the bottom,
So it hid the crack.
So as that crack already been, cracked.
And the drop that I just dropped,
So I'm going to the Apple Store to put this on.
I'm bringing it, and they have a cool little...
It's 5:37,
Pixel phone in,
You may notice that,
The time that I planned on going was,
Way earlier in the day,
But my phone did not backup in time,
So, here we are.
Now we are off to the Apple Store.
OK. Now we wait an hour and,
Go and check on our phone.
I should've planned on going to the gym,
but, hum.
I guess I'll go to Starbucks.
I just went to Starbucks, and
I brought something that I'm going to make a video
I would show you here, but...
But what kind of YouTuber will I be,
If I gave away, an incredible,
Clickbait title?
For this video, and it's actually not clickbait
Because the title, is actually true,
Of what I'm gonna show you in the video,
But it's such... Oh God!
I'm so excited!
I just turned this terrible day,
Into a really great day,
I'm stucked in the door.
And now I'm just gonna sit,
in my car because I have nothing else to do.
For the next half hour.
So,
Alright, we are going back to the Apple Store.
It's been about an hour,
I sat in my car,
I ran out of things to do,
I checked my email,
I just,
Don't know what else to do.
Hi I'm seeing if my phone is ready...
(Name?)
Ezarik, Justine.
Here's my new phone.
My poor little guy.
(Perfect.)
No! look.
Alright, case is on.
It's time to go.
I think everything is working out ok,
It's not quite even, but I tried my best.
But the best was not good enough.
Restoring from backup, Estimating time
Come on, let me know.
4 minutes? 5... oh. OK I see what's happening.
You excited that I'm home honey?
Hi. Oh good sit, very good.
Good morning.
It's the day after.
The day after the shatter.
Everything looks to be back in order,
I don't like the white case on this phone.
At all, it just doesn't... It doesn't look good,
The ecstatic is off,
But it did found this, in the drawer,
This is our little baby.
It's our classic iPhone.
It's the original, it started it all.
8, Gigs.
Anyway, I just wanna say Thanks for watching,
And I'm going to try to be,
More responsible.
Yeah, I don't know. I just woke up,
I need my Yerba Mate,
And, I'm gonna edit this video.
Alright, Thanks for watching,
Hopefully I won't be making any more of these videos.
So I'll see you later.
(Preview of previous video)